so during our last episode of comics and
coffee I asked you all to head over to
the forums at the weekly poll net and
post up your top 5 choices for Marvel
vs. DC battles and I would upload that
video for my top 5 Tuesday video well
the response was incredible you guys
posted up so many different battles and
so what I've done here is I've compiled
a list of what I consider to be the best
and most interesting from the list that
you all had given me so the first battle
on our list comes from jump start with
the Incredible Hulk vs. doomsday now as
you guys know the Incredible Hulk has
virtually unlimited strength that's tied
directly to his anger the angrier he
gets the stronger he gets and while his
strength has varied over the years the
best display came during World War Hulk
when he stomped on the ground in New
York and shook the entire East Coast now
where the Incredible Hulk has infinite
strength doomsday has adaptation who
doomsday is a culmination of a clone
being exposed to the harshest of
environments dying to those environments
and then being cloned again each time
becoming impervious to what it was it
had previously killed him now both of
these characters have healing factors
and a resistance level high enough to
survive nuclear explosions and the
destruction of planets so I would say
that this fight would ultimately end up
coming down to brute strength having
said that I think this will actually end
up being a draw with Doomsday's ability
to adapt to what had previously killed
him and Hulk's strength being limitless
I would say it would turn into an
endless cycle of doomsday dying and
coming back to life only to be killed
again by the Incredible Hulk
so the next battle on our list comes
from Hayase 83 with Superman vs. Darwin
now since there wasn't a version of
Superman that was specified here we're
going to go with Silver Age Superman
since that is arguably when he was at
his most powerful in addition to
Superman's normal run of abilities which
include heat vision and x-ray vision
Silver Age Superman was strong enough to
pull multiple planets out of their
galaxies and to the other side of the
universe as well as being able to
actually fly fast enough to break the
time barrier and travel through time now
Darwin and Marvel Comics is more of
and obscure character much like doomsday
Darwin had the ability to adapt and his
ability actually manifested itself with
his birth the difference here is that
we're dudes they had to die in order to
adapt Darwin adapts in real time if
Darwin's head were to be plunged into a
tank of water he would develop gills and
if he suddenly found himself in the
depths of space his body would adapt to
the lack of oxygen having said that my
vote here goes to Darwin due to the fact
that Darwin's ability to adapt since
birth means Superman traveling into the
past wouldn't really matter since Darwin
would adapt as a newborn baby to
whatever it is a Superman try to do to
him
in addition Darwin could also adapt into
any material that's strong enough to
withstand the physical strength of
Superman and that Darwin himself would
most likely adapt his full body or part
of his body into kryptonite in order to
simply kill Superman
now the next battle on our list comes
from Jay Walker with Batman versus Iron
Man now to me this is one of the more
intriguing battles on our list as we
know both Tony Stark and Batman are
billionaires with vast resources and
knowledge where iron man has knowledge
in artificial intelligence and all forms
of science Batman does as well but
Batman also has his abilities as a
detective on his side having said that
the battle would most likely come down
to a physical one and that Tony Stark
would likely be able to hack any of the
computerized devices that Batman would
use the Tony would most likely allow his
ego to get in the way as well which
would give Batman the upper hand and
disabling the Iron Man armor using some
kind of a low-tech device from there
Tony would lose since he just doesn't
have the kind of martial arts abilities
a Batman has since again this would
ultimately come down to a physical fight
between the two of them the sub number
two on our list comes from SAR breezy
with red hood versus Bucky Barnes now
this is going to be a tough one because
these two are incredibly even with Jason
Todd we know that his new 52 history
told us that he was trained by the
world's top minds and demolition combat
ology martial arts and espionage not to
mention his detective experience under
Batman how
ever and this is a big however we can't
discount Bucky Barnes since he was
trained by the United States Special
Forces Captain America and the Russians
and demolitions combat ology martial
arts and espionage as well in addition
to this unlike Jason Todd who's more
cocky and arrogant with his abilities
Bucky Barnes is a no-nonsense fighter
that doesn't really get caught up in the
moment that is to say he focuses on
exactly what it is that he's doing at
any particular point in time ultimately
though I would have to give this fight
to Jason Todd the reason for this is
that while Jason Todd would initially be
a little cocky and arrogant
he'd pick up on the seriousness of Bucky
Barnes very fast in addition to this
Jason Todd would also realized that
while Bucky Barnes is a 4-digit fighter
his robotic arm enables him to deal more
damage than his non robotic arm and so
as a result Jason Todd would most likely
disable the robotic arm very early into
the fight this combined with his
experience as a master of a multitude of
disciplines of martial arts would allow
him to overcome Bucky Barnes although
again it would be a very difficult feat
for him to achieve now number one comes
from jor-el of Dolton and this is
Deadpool vs. the Joker now as soon as I
saw this I knew this had to be number
one and to be honest I don't think
there's any real doubt here that
Deadpool would win due to his healing
factor but man would this be a
hysterical fight to see truthfully I
wouldn't see this fight lasting very
long Joker would most likely run through
his normal bag of goodies which include
his I guess there's acidic lapel his
several knives and so on and so forth
and eventually he would probably settle
on Joker venom but Deadpool of course
having his healing factor would be
virtually immune to Joker venom in
addition to this Deadpool would
constantly talk about nonsense and break
the fourth wall which would drive the
Joker nuts says he wouldn't know who
Deadpool was talking to and so the fight
itself would most likely end with the
Joker just kind of giving up and then
just going home
that's really the only way I see this
happening I don't really see I don't
really see what's happening any other
way what that being said let me know in
the comments section which characters
you would have chosen out of this top
five list of Marvel vs. DC battles and I
will catch you guys later
peace